So children, the thing that you guys
noticed here is called bursting of
tyre. Now why does this tire burst? The
simple reason is that whenever you
travel a long distance on the highway, it is because of
friction over a time period.  Tires have a
temperature and the temperature value of the air inside them
increases
and due to increase in temperature the
pressure inside also increases a lot
and if the quality of the tire is not good
then at the end it will be  Is tire
bursting a normal thing? That's why
whenever a journey is made on the highway,
normally truck drivers keep their air pressure
a little less than the standard value
so that they do not have to face the case of tire bursting
because it is a major cause
of accidents.  Region can also be made, so if
you guys like this concept then like this video
immediately and don't forget to share.